hey guys Justin hey Walt here and Rob
handler II from gamespot comm we checked
out Bioshock surprisingly on iOS
now let's version of the game maybe not
the absolute best version
you got to play around with both the
controller version and on the iPad
version what did you think about how to
gain control over all animals compared
to the original um well you first
started off with just the iOS stress
screen and it was difficult and then you
switch the controller and not
surprisingly it's amazing it completely
makes the game playable I on the other
hand got the controller first and then
went right to the touch screen and just
immediately said no in my mind yeah so I
jumped into the game the first thing I
did was say you know I'll try it out we
were working on getting the controller
working and I died like immediately yeah
but plugging against playing with a
controller you know it feels like the
regular game the controls map to the
mobile controller that's there kind of
tying in it's not tied directly into the
game you'll be able to get this
controller that works with these kind of
first-person experiences but Bioshock to
me it's a game that holds up and I
haven't played it in a couple years but
going back to it I was like you know I I
can't wait to experience that in this
world again I remember it being an
immersive crazy dystopian future right
how do you feel about how the game looks
well yeah I mean I played it actually
also like two years ago and you know got
through it and really enjoyed it um but
then you see on the iOS and you're
losing things that you really need in
the game like like that you need the
lighting and there really isn't any
light
it's just texture probably less modeling
is dumbed down it's more simplistic it's
Anaya what you see and you go oh this is
iOS know what I mean it's in iOS game
you you can't expect it to look as good
as it is going to look on on your Prezi
and so there they had to make some
things not look quite as good now in the
textures especially stand out like
you're walking you're like this problem
this is not your scheme but you have to
make those concessions and like for me I
felt like I accepted that like to be
able to play this portably if that was
something I want to do right like this
is this still works it's still the
Bioshock role it does it still works and
then but it really comes back to is am i
playing this
comfortably so the control is on on the
iPad like you basically pick it up in
that I think this is the way it's gonna
work on the phone as well no matter
where you put down your left thumb
that's gonna be controlling your
character and right I thought that
worked really well for it blowing the
world and interacting with objects all
of your other commands are tied to your
right thumb basically which led to a few
problems in combat definitely and we I'm
actually glad we played on the hearts of
difficulty to see you know can you get
through it
I mean and we're talking first ten
minutes the game and it was basically
impossible but we're playing and you got
you got you're moving on the left and on
the right you got look and everything
else and it's easy to switch between
your powers I mean you have your plasmid
powers of course which are integral to
Bioshock right have your weapons it's
actually I thought it was easy to switch
between those powers right it is but can
I do these things simultaneously in a
moment where like you know you have two
guys basically shooting you up and you
do rummage through some dead bodies and
hopefully get some health and what do I
have to do I have to basically stop what
I'm doing look down then use another
button to go through it by the time you
look up you're already dead yeah in the
heat of battle when you're trying to
both strength and move around the guy at
the same time you kind of have to make a
choice on are you gonna straight for are
you going to look up and down and try
that to really fast get your aim right
on that guy's head right and then when
also you need to use a help pack like
that's a different button entirely right
the health pack basically is the top
left where your health icon is you have
to either I mean I assume stop moving to
move up to push it or do a kind of like
a diagonal crossover with your right
hand and then again not look be able to
look or use any kind of weapon if you
have to stop what you're doing at any
moment for like an FPS to basically gain
health that's gonna be a major offense
so speaking of the game's other control
limitations
I think jump was one of the things that
was missing right they completely took
that out the reasons being I'm not sure
well it's not a Mario game it's not like
you need to jump to get around there's a
shells coming at you and then yeah and
then also there's another control
problem that I was a little scared of
was basically one direction of filtering
through your weapons so if you wanted to
you know shocking someone and switch
back to your like an assault rifle you
got basically two
Oh through the whole psyche one or two
get to whatever desired what we want and
what we saw is an unfinished build of
the game so those are potentially things
they could fix in a in an update that
would make the UI a little bit easier to
go through but from what we played yeah
there was one direction that you could
cycle through all of your weapons and as
that weapon this grows that could be
kind of problematic in the heat of
battle so this is gonna be a premium
game we don't know exactly how much it's
going to cost you probably assume at
least 15 bucks whining yeah and I think
one of the problems with a game like
this is that Bioshock is something you
can get really cheap and they've been
able to get really cheap in all these
bundles for picked at Bioshock series
for like what limbs like 9 bucks 6 bucks
early earliest you're like it's an
interesting experiment to say the least
and you know it I think it speaks to an
interesting future where 2k might be
bringing some more titles over in the
future and and I do like the controller
maybe not something I would carry around
personally right but it does definitely
makes playing these iOS games I'm
playing these full experiences these
full first-person shooter games mmm more
manageable but you know that is a
surprise announcement Bioshock coming to
iOS and if you want to read more about
it stay tuned to game spot com